In this video, we'll look at porting our content
out of our Unity project and into our new Unreal Engine project.
So this diagram is pulled from the Epic Games
Unity to Unreal documentation page.
We see a comparison of asset types inside of Unreal
and asset types inside of Unity and their supported formats.
The key things to note here are going to be some of the ones
that we covered already.
A Unity Mesh is a Static Mesh in Unreal Engine,
a Skinned Mesh is a Skeletal Mesh in Unreal Engine.
Animations are referred to as animation sequences,
but textures, audio files, video files, fonts,
GLTF and SpeedTree models are all called the same thing.
So now let's take a look at the Unity FBX Exporter.
If you have FBX models from your artist team
that you're working with already,
you'll be able to import those directly.
But if you have content that's been created inside of Unity,
or you want to group a cluster of FBXs together into a new one,
then we can do that with the Unity FBX Exporter.
Similarly, if you've authored any animations inside of Unity,
and you want those animations to come through
with their relevant objects or, yeah, their relevant Meshes,
the Unity FBX Exporter
is how we can keep everything grouped together.
It's important to note, though, that lights, cameras, volumes,
and custom script components
are not going to be able to come through.
The only things that we can get across
are going to be Mesh Assets, animations, and media files.
So let's take a look.
Here in Unity, we have our collection of Meshes
called State that I've named Stage Objects.
This is a collection of seven cubes
and a platform that our dancer is standing on.
So we can bring this over as one asset.
We have them selected here.
We can right-click, go to Export FBX.
We can call these, I'll call these Session Stage Objects.
I'll pick the folder I want them exported into.
This is this exported folder.
We have our source transform object.
In this case, I only want the models.
ASCII is good for that.
I had one named Key Instances. Perfect.
So I'll hit Export.
And now if we look in our Exports folder,
we have our Session Stage Objects.
You also see another one from where we were doing this earlier.
So for the next one, we are going to export our demo dancer.
So even we can right-click on her, Export to FBX.
We can go down to Models Only
and switch this to Models Plus Animation and Skin Mesh.
Everything else should be good to go.
Hit Export. Instead of overriding, we'll call this Session.
And here she is. Fantastic.
So now that we have, we can go ahead and save our unit.
But for instance, in this case, we have a timeline in here.
We have our stage lights.
We have a camera, directional light.
These things are not going to come through into Unreal.
So we unfortunately will need to rebuild either the logic around those
or the reposition them, add them to their equivalents
to our level inside of Unreal session content.
There it is.
So as we saw when we were exporting our assets out of Unity,
when you're exporting skinned meshes,
which are going to be character assets with their animations,
make sure you have Models Plus Animation selected
and make sure your export path is also configured correctly.
For regular meshes, just make sure in the options
that it's set to Models Only, and you should be good to go.
Another thing I'd like to call out here
before we look at importing our FBXs into Unreal
is the Unity Reporter.
This is very similar to Unreal Engine's Tape Reporter feature.
This allows you to render out videos from a camera
or record game object properties during play or simulation.
This is really useful for recording physics simulations
or game objects that are animated via the timeline
or animated via script.
If you know you have something set and it doesn't need to change
and you just need to get it over quickly
and you don't want to do all of that same work,
we can use the recorder.
Let's look over here in Unity.
This cube that's floating will now make a little more sense.
We have our Rigidbody enabled, so when we press Play,
look up here, we'll see our cube fall to the ground.
What if we wanted to bring that cube in and have that same animation logic
or have this same simulation play exactly the way that we want it to?
We can do this over here in the Unity Recorder.
Here we have our cube selected.
We want to record its transform into an FBX.
We don't need its hierarchy.
We would like the geometry source.
Let's drag in, drag this in again.
Actually, let's leave this as not.
Here we have the name of the animation file,
and it will be saved into assets folder.
Recordings, it's okay.
Take number two, and I'll hit Start Recording.
Stop recording, awesome.
So now if we look here,
we can see our cube animation waiting for us.
Now let's get to importing our assets into Unreal.
When importing static meshes for this,
we're mostly just going to leave it to the default settings.
There is an option to combine separate meshes into one,
but for us, in this instance, leaving them separate
makes it easier to make adjustments to them individually,
which we'll do later on in the session.
So we'll go Import.
We will look for our exports.
Session stage objects open.
Source name for asset is good.
We can apply different translation or rotation offsets.
Static meshes import.
We do not want them to be combined.
Import collision, that all looks good, okay.
Import, it looks like they all came in together
to start with, but we can see that our separate materials
did not come through, and they all just share one
calibration mat of the platform.
So let's bring in now our session demo dancer.
In this case, we will again leave everything to blank,
but for the animations, or everything to default,
but in animations, I believe we can.
This snap to closest frame boundary
will help prevent some warnings we get
during the import process.
Import, and here we see all of our dancer assets.
There's quite a few.
We have our skeletal mesh here is waiting for us,
but it appears she is facing the other direction.
See if we drag her in.
She's facing over to, how can we fix that?
So when importing skeletal mesh assets,
we also are gonna be able to leave this
mostly to default for now, but one thing to note
is that we want to have import animations checked
and snap to closest frame boundary also checks
to help prevent warnings on import.
When we're all done, these should be
all the different assets that we see.
In our case, we have all of our cubes combined
and stage assets combined together,
so we can work on splitting those apart a little bit later.
Once again, we can save everything by clicking the button
in the bottom right corner of that.
We noticed though that when we dragged our character in,
they are now facing to the right.
This is due to a difference in Unity
and Unreal's coordinate axes,
although this is changing in an upcoming version
of Unreal again, but it should make this transition
between the two programs a little bit easier.
For now though, if we want to have our character
come in facing the correct direction,
what we need to do is go to our skeletal mesh here,
report mesh with dialogue.
Then here, let's see if we change our Z rotation by 90
and import what that looks like,
and now she's facing the right way.
Amazing.
And we want to go ahead and make sure we save her.
There we go.
So next, let's drag in our static meshes
into our level.
So here we can drag in our stage objects.
I'm gonna put it here so that I can situate it
around our platform here.
So I think that'll look cool.
Awesome.
And then again, in this case,
instead of re-importing the static mesh,
I'm just going to rotate it 90 degrees
using its transform component here.
I think that will give us,
or that'll get it lined up nice and right.
And this will look really cool.
All right, not too bad.
If you want to check in the same way in Unity,
you can go into orthographic views up here
where the perspective camera is.
This dropdown is in Unreal.
This is where we can also go up
to look at an orthographic view inside of the viewport.
By default, everything is this wireframe view.
If you'd like to switch it from wireframe additionally,
here you can go and see it lit or unlit rendering.
But I generally find,
when I'm going to line things up perfectly up here,
it's kind of nice to have it in the wireframe view.
You can go back to our perspective.
Fantastic.
In the next video,
we'll be taking a look at how to create
different kinds of blueprints.